buenas tardes desde la capital británica
si esa es la pregunta del día según el
telegraph el príncipe andrew pagará a
virginia joffré ya su organización de
caridad que apoya a las víctimas del
abuso sexual 12 millones de libras
esterlinas lo que son más de 16 millones
de dólares sin embargo la mensualidad de
la pensión del duque de york como piloto
de la armada británica no sería
suficiente no habría manera para que
pagara semejante cifra así que es claro
que la reina isabel tendrá que usar
parte de su riqueza personal para pagar
por este acuerdo la reina no puede
utilizar los recursos públicos que
provienen de los impuestos de los
británicos para pagar por esta acuerdo
porque sería devastador para el futuro
de la monarquía y la reina así lo sabe
también el príncipe carlos el heredero a
la corona habría precipitado llegar a
este acuerdo económico para evitar que
este escándalo siguiera eclipsando la
celebración de los 70 años del reinado
de isabel se gusta luisa rápidamente
hablando del futuro cuál es el una
familia real y le pregunto si va a
recuperar entonces sus títulos
evito la vergüenza pública de enfrentar
un juicio civil en una corte de nueva
york pero es poco probable que recupere
sus honores y títulos militares y así
como su lugar activo como miembro de la
familia real y es que las acusaciones de
presunto acuse de abuso sexual a una
menor de edad han sido devastadoras para
la reputación del duque de york también
hemos podido ver en este acuerdo lo que
se conoce el porqué probablemente nunca
sabremos todos los detalles es el cambio
del tono del duque que inicialmente se
ha negado a reconocer que conoció a
virginia joffré y pese a que existe una
foto de los dos y ahora habla de
reconocer y apoyar a las víctimas de
abuso sexual